something you might know if you've seen
any of my videos is that i find it
interesting to take a look
at the different exams that people have
to sit around the world
and for various subjects so when one
particular exam was in the news recently
i was intrigued to take a look at it
last week
kim kardashian revealed that she had
failed her
baby bar exam something taken by
first-year law students
in california before they are able to go
on
and study for three more years to
eventually take the big
californian bar exam which would qualify
them to practice as an attorney
the fact that kim is even studying law
may be news to you
that's okay but i found this story
and this exam to actually be pretty
interesting
in short kim has been trying to use her
massive public profile for good
and help people who have been done wrong
by america's criminal justice system
she met with donald trump and was
successful in getting him to grant
clemency
to several people who she had fought for
including alice johnson
who had already served 21 years of her
life sentence
given to her for a non-violent
first-time drug offense
kim has been working alongside human
rights attorneys
to help reform aspects of america's
prison system
but now she wants to be more than just a
celebrity attached to the work
and she wants to be a qualified attorney
herself
kim said that the best way to change a
system
is to know the system the traditional
way to become a lawyer
is to go to law school for three years
after
a four-year bachelor's degree but kim is
doing it a slightly different way
that is similar to an apprenticeship she
is working with an attorney
18 hours a week for four years before
she'll be able to sit the final
californian bar exam
to become qualified after the first year
of this
she's able to sit the baby bar exam to
prove that she's on the right track
but this has become a bit of a hurdle
the baby bar is offered twice per year
and i've been able to figure out that
kim would have sat the june
2020 exam which means that these here
are the actual questions that kim would
have got on her exam
and they're from the state bar website
so let's have a look at them
the exam goes for seven hours and
consists of
essays and multiple choice questions
these are some of the essay questions
the first one is about torts law which
is when someone commits a wrong
against another person it says mal was
late for an important meeting
and was driving at least 35 miles an
hour on a residential road
the speed limit on this road was 30
miles per hour
as mel rounded a curve in the road nigel
suddenly backed out of his driveway
in front of mel mel's headlights were on
and his lights would have been visible
if a driver had looked carefully
to avoid hitting nigel's car mel both
braked hard
and turned into the center of the street
crossing a yellow line
and partially entering the lane of
oncoming traffic otto was driving
towards mel
while adjusting his car radio as a
result
otto did not see mel in time had he been
attentive
he likely could have avoided an accident
instead
the two cars collided left the road
and plowed into penny who was walking on
the sidewalk
nigel's car was not touched penny was
seriously injured
then the question asks what claims penny
can make
against mel otto and nigel
now i don't have any background in law
but we can take a look at one of the
example solutions that scored highly
it's actually pretty in-depth and goes
through all of the possible charges for
everyone involved
here's starting with penny versus mel
it's
looking at whether mel has been
negligent or breached his duty to act as
a reasonably prudent person
there's a need to establish actual and
proximate causation
and to assess any defenses that mel
might be able to use
then the same thing over again for penny
versus otto
where otto may argue that glancing at
the radio every now and again
doesn't count as unreasonable behavior
and who actually caused the accident
will
again come into dispute and then for
penny versus nigel
the one who backed out of his driveway
it is likely that nigel will be found to
have been in breach of his duty to act
reasonably
given that he hadn't looked carefully
when he was backing out
in conclusion penny will likely be
successful in a negligence claim against
nigel
but will most likely fail in her claims
of negligence against mel and otto it of
course wouldn't be enough to just state
a conclusion of the case
but rather to argue every point for and
against each person
and really show an understanding of
applying all the legal principles
question two is about contract law and
regards a buyer
who purchased ten five thousand dollar
guitars for fifty thousand dollars
and agreed that any complaints about the
condition or quality of the guitars
must be made within 10 days of delivery
and that payment is due on delivery
however the buyer did not pay the
invoice and
two weeks after the instruments were
delivered found that none of their
customers wanted to buy them in their
store
and so sent them back the seller sued
the buyer for breach of contract
and were asked what arguments the seller
could make in support of her claim
and what defenses the buyer may use also
what would be the likely outcome
so then in this example answer we've got
a few pages of going through all the
definitions and
things that were agreed to in this
contract establishing that we did have a
valid contract
in what terms it was reasonable to
expect the buyer and seller to abide by
it might have been okay for the buyer to
return the guitars without paying for
them
if the guitars had not been conforming
in quality or some other means
but just because the guitars weren't
selling in the store
does not speak to any non-conformity of
the guitars
and so the seller is not in breach and
the contract
expressly required that the buyer make
this determination within 10 days of
delivery
not 14. so in conclusion
the court would find that the buyer was
in breach of the contract
and would be liable to seller for 50
000.
this third question is a real doozy and
it starts off pretty
intense doug decided to kill bob
the owner of a small grocery store
because bob had twice falsely accused
doug of shoplifting
it only gets more and more intense from
here this question is an example of
criminal law doug went into bob's store
and killed bob
by shooting him twice with a handgun
after the shooting
doug noticed the cash register went over
and opened it
and took all of the money out doug then
saw a customer
sally hiding behind some shelves he
pointed the gun at sally
took her purse and tied her hands behind
her back
doug then heard police sirens and
ordered sully at gunpoint
out of the store and into his car
officer fran
who was responding to a report of
gunshots at bob's store
saw doug speed out of the parking lot in
his car
officer fran chased him for several
blocks until doug
pulled into an empty parking lot when he
got out of his car
doug fired several shots at officer fran
who responded by firing her gun at doug
she missed but one of her bullets went
through the window of the car
and hit sally killing her as doug tried
to run away
officer fran tackled him and knocked the
gun out of his hand
doug got up and punched officer fran
with his fist
officer fran then subdued and arrested
doug
heck with what crimes can doug
reasonably be charged
what defenses if any may he reasonably
raise
and what is the likely result going
through the charges here we've got the
murder
of bob first of all the state will be
able to show
that doug was the cause of bob's death
and they'll be able to show that there
was
malice and intent then they'll need to
decide whether they want to charge
doug with murder 1 murder 2 or voluntary
manslaughter
for murder 1 they would need to show
that
doug murdered bob with premeditation and
deliberation
and for that the state is likely to
charge doug with murder 1
and for him to be convicted then there
are all the other crimes
there's a likely charge for the robbery
of bob's money from the store
there's also the robbery of sally's
purse
the assault of sally and the battery of
sally
continuing we have the false
imprisonment of sally
the kidnapping of sally the assault of
officer fran
and then they'll need to consider the
murder of sally as well
the state will need to go through the
same analysis that they did with the
murder of bob
but then who would be charged with this
would it be doug as well
or would it be officer fran since it was
a bullet from her gun
well apparently that depends on which
version of the law
certain courts follow in certain areas
if the courts follow the common law
the state will be able to show that doug
did murder in the first degree
sally under the felony murder rule but
if that can't be shown
then the state may have to consider
charging doug with involuntary
manslaughter for sally's death
actually in neither of these cases is
officer fran charged
and then the last charge for doug would
be the battery of officer fran
and there's a fourth question here that
we can just take a quick glance at
it's another torts question it's about
someone who does some work on their land
that also affects their neighbor's
vacant lot even though the neighbor is
away for a year
they chop down the neighbor's tree and
install a septic system which
infringes on their property when the
neighbor gets back they're angry about
this
and decide to sue for the damages a
spoiler here
is that despite the involvement of an
innocent contractor who actually is the
one who did the work
it is the guy who ordered the work to be
done who would remain directly liable
for the tortious conduct he exhibited
the maximum score
is 800 and to pass you need 70 percent
which is 560. kim scored
474 and she said she studied for
six weeks 10 to 12 hours per day for the
exam
which is a solid effort kim was clearly
disheartened
and upset in the announcement of her
results
but really kim hasn't done that badly
especially when you consider
the passing rate for her exam for first
time takers in june 2020 it was only
27.6
meaning that most people need to retake
this exam
and from what i can tell the way that
kim is pursuing her studies
isn't any easier than the conventional
path having to learn a lot of these
concepts through
largely self-led reading may be harder
in some aspects than
being taught by professors and
surrounded by peers
i have nothing bad to say about kim i
respect that she's trying to better
herself
and is open to sharing her failures
along the way
i do hope that she passes her next
attempt at the exam
which may have been the november 2021
or the upcoming june 2021 exam
thanks for watching this video i have a
whole playlist
full of other exam videos although
mostly physics and math ones
thanks to my patreon supporters for
making these videos possible
and a special shout out to today's
patreon cat of the day
[Music]
krishna
you